So the next technique in Stratton's Optimization Taxonomy is called the scatter-to-gather transformation.
Now most interesting computations involve a step
where many input elements contribute to the computation of an output element.
So in this example the elements labeled blue in the input array
are contributing to the blue element in the output array,
and the elements labeled green in the input array are contributing to the green in the output array and so forth.
And examples from you homework included blurring the image or computing a histogram.
And sometimes, of course, the locations of the input elements
that will contribute to particular output element
aren't know ahead of time like in a histogram example.
And we've talked about the difference between scatter and gather.
In scatter the threads are assigned to the input elements,
and each one is deciding where it needs to write.
In gather the threads were signed to the output elements,
and each one decides where he needs to go read from.
So here's a quick quiz which should be pure review.
Which code snippet represents a gather, and which one will run more efficiently?
Here's code snippet 1, and here's code snippet 2.
In each of these cases you can assume that out and in
are arrays of floating point numbers and that i represents the thread index.